les jeux de moscou compromis carter
demande à l'europe de s'aligner sur le
boycott amérique la sphère de breuil
communistes et socialistes vont demander
au parlement de saisir la haute cour
la natalité en france comment améliorer
la fécondité du coup là monsieur bonsoir
les jeux sont faits rien ne va plus ou
presque
cette expression chère aux habitués des
casinos pourrait très bien s'appliquer
aux problèmes des jeux olympiques de
moscou après la décision du comité
olympique américain de ne pas envoyer
d'athlètes à moscou après avec cette
décision la politique est entré cette
fois de plain pied et à visage découvert
dans le monde sportif
contrairement à l'habitude la nouvelle a
été aussitôt diffusée en union
soviétique par la télévision et les
journaux de moscou notre envoyé spécial
chaque à bouche
jimmy carter est devenu la bête noire
l'ennemi numéro 1 des russes un
hystérique un hystérique et un excité
écrivent les commentateurs et il ajoute
le peuple américain et contre le
boycottage les athlètes voulait venir à
moscou
mais carter a opté pour une politique de
guerre froide les journaux soviétique
près le président pour cible unique
il s'agit pour eux de le dissocier de
l'opinion américaine et de l'europe
la grande peur des russes c'est que
l'exemple américain soit suivie par de
nombreux pays occidentaux et que les
jeux de moscou se déroule avec la
participation des seuls athlètes dépit
du camp socialiste alors minimise la
portée du boycottage à la télévision
soviétique qu'hier soir la décision du
comité olympique américain a été traité
en fin du journal en quelques mots et
elle tient en trois lignes dans le
quotidien la pravda de ce jour pourtant
la déception est nettement perceptible
on espérait une fête grandiose dans des
installations prestigieuse et il est
évident que sans les athlètes et les
nageurs les états unis il y aura moins
d'émotions fortes peu de suspense et
pour tout dire le coeur d'israël
vraiment plu aux états unis on pourrait
résumer l'opinion des américains en
disant que si les athlètes sont déçus
l'opinion publique est satisfaite
puisque le dernier sondage indiquent
qu'une grande majorité des américains
est favorable au boycottage
une décision qui devrait donc permettre
au président carter de remonter dans la
course à la maison blanche
en effet le dernier sondage indiquait
que 49% des américains désapprouvaient
sa politique surtout dans la sphère
iranienne cette fermeté donc dans le
domaine des jeux olympiques peut lui
permettre de remonter la pente de
washington notre correspondant jacques c
qui suivit carter avait multiplié les
mises en garde et les pressions en
direction du comité olympique américain
tué en faisant valoir que la sphère de
la sécurité nationale le gouvernement
américain et s'est assuré du résultat du
vote
on notera au passage que l'expression
sécurité nationale a toujours été un des
moyens de pression favorise de
l'histoire américaine
aujourd'hui les athlètes de ce pays est
déçu de la majorité constate que c'est
la politique qui a prévalu face aux
grands princes tandis que l'entourage du
président on attend presque avec
confiance que l'europe à son tour au nom
ce rendez-vous de moscou ou ça casse et
les 12 ou quatre ans devrait être une
nouvelle fois prolongé leur affrontement
par d'autres moyens
combien de vous le laissez entendre
jacques sébi la décision du comité
olympique américain risque bien sûr
d'entraîner la défection de nombreux
autres pays qui hésitaient encore du
moins officiellement
et aussi influencer les autres notamment
les européens friands capteurs dans
l'interview qu'il a accordée aux
télévisions européennes a mis tout le
poids de la puissance de son pays dans
la balance aussi bien dans la sphère des
jeux olympiques que dans la sphère
iranienne parmi les nations les plus
importantes qui doivent maintenant se
décider
l'allemagne fédérale dont le comité
olympique doit se réunir demain
mais déjà le chancelier schmid s'est
prononcé lui en faveur du boycottage de
bonnes michel meyer l'heure des
politesses et des sourires et donc passé
expressément invité par le président
carter à prendre parti en actes et non
plus en paroles il n'est plus question
pour helmut schmidt de gagner du temps
ou de manoeuvrer en marge du conflit
entre américains et soviétiques
le seuil est en effet atteint ou tout
désunion entre allemands et américains
profitent à l'union soviétique
ce qui reste tout à fait inadmissible
pour un homme politique allemand
ainsi et même si les effets de menton
comme l'on dit si du président carter
paraissent toujours aussi superflu est
surtout destinée à l'opinion d'une
amérique en campagne électorale et bien
les allemands suivront vraisemblablement
les américains mettrait à contre coeur
ce sera vrai en matière olympique avec
vraisemblablement d'ici la fin du mois
de mai une décision du comité olympique
allemand prévoyant l'absence d'athlètes
allemand à moscou mais ce sera surtout
vrai en matière de rétorsion économiques
envers l'iran et l'union soviétique
ces mesures risquent pourtant de coûter
très cher aux allemands beaucoup plus
cher en tout cas qu'aux américains eux
mêmes la 1ère et rachète en effet 15%
environ de son pétrole en iran toute
sanction allemande envers l'iran peut
donc signifier une pénurie de carburant
et même l'abandon du train de la
croissance économique
côté boycott économique de l'urss ces
cinq cent mille emplois qui dépendent
d'un commerce dont le volume a atteint
plus de 30 milliards de nos francs l'an
dernier
on comprend donc les hésitations et
lenteurs allemand
elle nous timide tentera donc au maximum
d'adopter une position européenne c'est
à dire essentiellement concertée avec le
président valéry giscard d'estaing cela
de façon à limiter au maximum
aussi les dégâts autant liée à
l'imprévisibilité du président carter
cas l'expansionnisme soviétique
on retrouve d'ailleurs très clairement
ce souci dans l'interview que nous
accorder tout récemment elle nous suit
au cours de son voyage aux etats-unis m
gauche prg et dans mes entretiens nous
dit il avec le président carter j'ai
beaucoup insisté précisément sur le fait
que pour atteindre les mêmes buts en
fonds pouvait au sein de notre alliance
avoir mis des rôles différents
à l'image d'un orchestre dans la musique
est le résultat de plusieurs instruments
musique va gêner instruments and had
l'engagement allemand dans le cadre
d'une europe plus autonome entre les
deux grands a cependant des limites très
précises ses limites se confondent avec
celles du triste mur de berlin et des 11
100 kilomètres de frontières de la rfa
avec l'est
on ne peut en effet refusé de se
solidariser avec une grande puissance
américaine qui reste ici le garant
nucléaires et conventionnelles de la
sécurité des berlinois et les allemands
de l'ouest
alors en ce qui concerne l'attitude du
gouvernement français pour l'instant pas
de prise de position plutôt toujours la
même au comité olympique français de se
décider mais il apparaît de plus en plus
que si les jeux olympiques de moscou ne
réunissent que des pays de l'est
le gouvernement sera amené à prendre
position pour le boycottage pierre
salière oui enfin je t'ai rude pour
l'instant effectivement le gouvernement
français se cantonne dans une attitude
prudente réserve et de wait and see
attendre et voir
et pour résumer la position
gouvernementale je me contenterai de
rappeler qu' elle n'a pas varié depuis
qu effectivement monsieur soissons
devant l'assemblée nationale a déclaré
un jour la décision de boycotter les
jeux et inapproprié il avait précisé au
figaro précisément si nous allons aux
jeux olympiques qu'il n'est pas question
de participer à des jeux
si ces jeux sont uniquement réservé les
pays de l'est ont manié spartak à cette
position n'a pas varié et chaque fois
qu'on leur lance d'ailleurs sur la
question le ministre de la jeunesse et
des sports renvoie la balle dans le camp
du comité olympique français en disant
c'est son affaire
justement quelle est la position du
comité olympique français balle est
connu depuis le depuis le 22 janvier
c'est d'ailleurs le premier comité avoir
pris position le comité
finale olympique et sportif français a
déclaré le 22 janvier nous irons aux
jeux olympiques est rude on joue on
précise encore aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
question de changer d'attitude
en tout cas on n'envoie pas un prétexte
précisément mais alors pourquoi la
réponse écrite officielle n'a toujours
pas été envoyé aux soviétiques
oui c'est un peu la question qu'on se
pose effectivement alors là il ya deux
versions la version officielle qui dit
nous avons jusqu'au 24 mai pour prendre
une décision
il n'y a pas de raison de s'affoler
après tout voyons ce que vont faire les
autres
sous-entendu et puis il ya une raison
plus officieuse il y a à l'heure
actuelle un contentieux entre paris et
moscou
ce contentieux porte sur une vulgaire
affaire datant dans ce jeu précise
s'agissant de l'encadrement de l'équipe
de france les soviétiques organisateurs
des jeux olympiques veulent appliquer
les quotas prévus par la charte
olympique
or les français se référant aux usages
demande le double d'accréditation pour
l'encadrement des kills de france et la
france précisent dans ce cas là si elle
n'obtient pas satisfaction de la part
des soviétiques
il n'est pas question d'envoyer une
délégation à moscou alors vous voyez
aussi critiquable soit le prétexte
voilà en tout cas un bon prétexte trouvé
pour un désistement de dernière minute à
moins à moins que d'ici là le
gouvernement français suivant ainsi
l'exemple du gouvernement américain du
gouvernement britannique et peut être
même du gouvernement allemand la prenne
la décision de boycotter les jeux
prenant ainsi la faire à son compte
comme il avait pris précédemment il n'y
a pas si longtemps la faire à son compte
s'agissant des rugbymen sud-africains
merci dernière réaction sur cette
affaire celle de monsieur françois
mitterrand invité de tf1 ce midi jusqu'à
présent le parti socialiste était
favorable la tenue des jeux mais les
derniers événements l'amène à moduler sa
position ou allez voir vous savez que le
parti socialiste avait refusé de
s'associer dans sa majorité à la
campagne de boycott
voilà la réalité le fait s'impose il
faut se rendre à l'évidence et en effet
les jeux olympiques si le doivent se
passer ou se dérouler simplement entre
quelques pays d'un camp politique perdre
leur signification
il faudra donc prévoir pour les jeux
olympiques d'autres façons de fait si
l'on veut les sauver
oui une dernière dépêche à propos de ces
jeux olympiques demain doit se réunir
demain donnera une conférence de presse
le comité olympique
soviétique donnera une conférence de
presse et l'on y commentera on n'en sait
pas plus on y commentera la décision
américaine c'est sans doute une réunion
assez importante pour l'avenir de ces
jeux olympiques
vous allez voir les premières images des
jardins de l'ambassade du pérou à la
vanne ou depuis plus d'une semaine sont
réfugiés plus de 10000 cubain candidats
à l'exil
ces images filmées par la télévision
mexicaine parviennent le jour même où un
début de solution semble se dessiner 500
réfugiés ont reçu leur visa pour le
pérou et plusieurs milliers d'autres ont
regagné leur domicile muni d'un
sauf-conduit dont il espère pouvoir se
servir dans les semaines qui viennent
gérard ce bac ses 10000 cubain candidats
à l'exil ont vécu une semaine
particulièrement et qu'on vante une
semaine ce debout serrés les uns contre
les autres
il est impossible de se coucher pour
dormir choses certains d'entre eux ont
même été contraints de s'installer sur
les toits de l'ambassade
l'attitude des autorités cubaines il
faut le souligner a été correcte dans la
mesure où ce sont eux qui ont organisé
l'assistance aux réfugiés à travers les
grilles aide aux bébés approvisionnement
en eau et en europe
cependant à proximité de l'ambassade qui
n'ont pas manqué d'organiser des
manifestations populaires contre les
traîtres action psychologique ou un
pantin représentant l'oncle sam été
brûlés les autorités cubaines vont donc
apparemment tenir leurs promesses et
laisser quitter le pays à ceux qui le
désirent
pour cela la première opération était de
délivrer des passeports et des sauf
conduits près de 2000 personnes ont
accepté de quitter l'ambassade en
prenant le risque de se voir fiche est
restée elle-même munis de leur passeport
et leur sauve conduit ils ont rejoint
leur domicile et il attend cependant les
autres ne faisant pas confiance préfère
rester à l'intérieur de l'ambassade ils
souhaitent des garanties solides pour
eux qui l'attend est un peu plus
confortable
il ya moins de monde et ils peuvent
maintenant ce soir sur la pelouse de
l'ambassade du pérou
le président du venezuela monsieur ra
campins est arrivé aujourd'hui en voyage
officiel en france le venezuela l'une
des rares démocraties de l'amérique
latine qui est aussi devenu un pays très
important par ses ressources en pétrole
bernard baigner
le lac de maracaibo l'un des hauts lieux
du miracle vénézuélien on y fort tous
les jours on y slalome entre les puits
le fonds est couvert de tuyaux qui
aspire le pétrole pour une production de
2 milliards et demi de barils par jour
70 % de l'ensemble de ses revenus
jusqu'à présent le venezuela s'était
surtout cela qu aujourd'hui l'intérêt
c'est un peu déplacé dans le bassin de
l'orénoque
il ay ay si un fabuleux gisement 100
milliards de tonnes de pétrole de
réserves
le problème c'est que ce gisement est
constituée d'huile lourde
extrêmement coûteuses à exploiter or la
france qui importe du venezuela 1 % de
sa consommation détient un brevet de
raffinage pour ce genre de pétrole la
suite on la devine avec cette technique
paris pourrait bien devenir l'un des
partenaires privilégiés de caracas
caracas cette capitale tentaculaire aux
trois millions d'habitants où les
immeubles poussent comme des champignons
ou les embouteillages sont célèbres dans
toute l'amérique du sud à 30 centimes le
litre d'essence
on n'hésite pas à prendre sa voiture
mais caracas qui recèle aussi le danger
de la démocratie vénézuélienne les
bidonvilles les rangs cheetos où vivent
un million de personnes
ici chaque jour la subversion gagne du
terrain profitant du dénuement total
dans lequel se trouvent les habitants ne
serrant cheetos l'équipe au pouvoir le
sait qui devant cette menace joue la
carte du social création d'emplois ou
reconversion de certains quartiers
c'est la seule façon de défendre la
démocratie dit le président herrera
campins qui vient demander à la france
de défendre les libertés en amérique
latine
il a d'ailleurs dit tout à l'heure à son
arrivée à orly oh non les cinq pays du
pacte andes
princesses des gaules un grand français
le général charles de gaulle lors de la
visite qu'il fit qu'en 64 venezuela a
affirmé que la france ne ménagerait
jamais son appui à la démocratisation de
l'amérique latine
aujourd'hui alors que nous deux pays
partagent la même angoisse face à la
situation tendue entre les grandes
puissances
nous sommes persuadés que cette promesse
est toujours actuelle madame indira
gandhi a échappé de justesse à un
attentat ce matin à new delhi un homme
lui a lancé un poignard de quelques
mètres qui n'a pas atteint mais qui a
blessé un des gardes du corps du premier
ministre indien à londres une centaines
de britanniques éleveur de moutons ont
manifesté devant l'ambassade de france
aujourd'hui pour protester contre le
refus français d'importer du mouton en
provenance d'angleterre et c'est un peu
si l'on peut dire la réponse du berger à
la bergère car rappelez vous il ya
quelques semaines les producteurs de
lait français s'était rendu alors on
peut manifester devant le parlement de
tanit cette fois contre la législation
qui refusent ou l'importation de lait
français et leur anglais réclame
maintenant aux consommateurs
britanniques de boycotter tous les
produits alimentaires français on ira
enfin pour la première fois aujourd'hui
une mission de la croix rouge
internationale a pu se rendre près les
otages mais à l'heure qu'il est la
délégation n'est toujours pas sorti de
l'ambassade et puis cet après midi
devant la chambre des communes par le
mot anglais
madame thatcher le premier ministre a
demandé que les pays de la communauté
européenne décide d'une action commune
dans la sphère des otages en iran et
elle a même fixé un délai elle a dit que
cette décision devait être prise par don
d'ici à lundi prochain en france affaire
de breuil les communistes et les
socialistes vont demander demain au
parlement la mise en place d'une
procédure de mise en accusation de
monsieur michel poniatowski devant la
haute cour de justice
monsieur payet ski qui était à l'époque
du meurtre de monsieur de breuil
ministre de l'intérieur et ce sont
justement ces déclarations que les
socialistes et les communistes lui
reproche
comment cette demande des deux groupes
de la gauche peut-elle aboutir
les explications de daniel brands
pour que cette procédure aboutisse il
faut que la proposition de résolution
communiste soit assortie de 50
signatures c'est facile que le bureau de
l'assemblée nationale donne le feu vert
c'est probable à partir de là une course
d'obstacles s'engage une commission
spéciale où l'opposition sera comme à
l'assemblée minoritaires doit dire oui
ou non si la haute cour souhaite être
saisie mais la décision finale
appartient à tous les députés et à tous
les sénateurs qui doivent se prononcer
au scrutin public à la majorité absolue
et dans des termes identiques changé
même une virgule
dans ces conditions la démarche des
communistes qui seront suivis demain
après midi par les socialistes at-elle
des chances d'aboutir et bien tout
dépend de 46 voix du groupe rpr ce
groupe se réunit demain après midi qu on
sera alors s'il est d'accord avec
monsieur foyer qui estime que rien ne
prouve que monsieur renier tout ce
qu'ils aient menti alors au centre de
toute cette agitation l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur a publié ce matin un
nouveau communiqué il dénonce je cite
les combats électoraux et affirme qu'il
n'a jamais dit il ya trois ans comme le
disent les socialistes et les
communistes que l'instruction judiciaire
de la sphère de breuil était terminé
mais au contraire qu'elle commençait
demain également parlement s'ouvre le
débat sur le projet de loi du
gouvernement sur l'actionnariat qui sera
suivi d'un autre débat sur la
participation des cadres à la gestion
des entreprises et à leur présence dans
les conseils d'administration premier de
ces textes a pour but de relancer par
une mesure exceptionnelle
l'actionnariat des salariés jean-louis
de seine et jacques martin
c'est à londres en novembre 42 que
charles de gaulle disait nous gagnerons
la guerre puis nous transformerons la
condition ouvrière mais c'est à
saint-etienne capitale du travail 10 est
il qu'il a pour la première fois évoqué
l'association capital travail le 4
janvier 48 exactement il y a aujourd'hui
32 ans
il s'agissait à l'époque d'intéresser
les travailleurs aux résultats
financiers les entreprises à
l'organisation du travail dans les
entreprises à la finalité d'entreprise
ces idées vont mettre du temps à faire
leur chemin puisqu'il faudra attendre le
17 ou 67 l'ordonance sur l'intéressement
des travailleurs une ordonnance qui
d'ailleurs ne sera appliquée que deux
années plus tard sous la présidence de
georges pompidou
l'actionnariat 10 et il est une
politique délibérée qui sera poursuivie
malgré tout les réticences la
participation sera par ailleurs l'un des
axes de la nouvelle société prôné par le
premier ministre de l'époque jacques
chaban delmas
deux conditions sont alors imposés aux
entreprises qu'elles aient plus de 100
employés et bien sûr que leur bilan soit
positif nos conditions et trois
possibilités mettre le montant de la
participation sur un compte courant dans
l'entreprise intérêts 7% environ
le placées en sicav ou pour les sociétés
par actions le distribuer en action
c'est cette dernière solution que
souhaitait voir appliquer le général de
gaulle car les salariés pouvaient alors
influer sur la gestion générale de leur
entreprise aujourd'hui en 1981 la
réserve de participation bloquée pour
cinq ans a beau représenter en france 13
milliards et demi lourd
elle ne concerne que 4 millions et demi
de salariés sur 13 millions
c'est sans doute ce chiffre qui outre
des conditions d'ordre strictement
politique a poussé valéry giscard
d'estaing a annoncé que le mouvement
allait être amplifiées
ce projet de loi fera en effet la
possibilité pour les entreprises qui le
désirent de distribuer à leurs
personnels 3% du capital social
à l'origine cette mesure devait être
obligatoire elle n'est plus maintenant
que facultative
pour bénéficier de cette distribution
d'actions la seule condition posée aux
salariés est d'avoir deux ans
d'ancienneté
ces nouveaux actionnaires auront la
plénitude des droits dont jouissent les
actionnaires classique
ils auront le droit de vote dans les
assemblées générales et pourront bien
sûr percevoir des dividendes
seule différence ces actions ne pourront
être librement vendus avant un certain
délai qui reste à déterminer
le financement de cette opération
exceptionnelle sera assuré aux deux
tiers par l'état
celui ci remettra aux sociétés une
créance d'un montant égal à
l'augmentation du capital réalisée cette
créance sera porteuse intérêt est
remboursable en plusieurs hannut et ou
de cette opération environ 200 millions
de francs qui seront fournies par une
taxe sur les cadeaux et les frais de
réception des entreprises
les textes sur la participation ne
compromette en aucune manière en
autorité nécessaire du chef d'entreprise
ni l'efficacité de l'entreprise c'est ce
que souligne monsieur raymond barre dans
une interview qui paraîtra demain matin
dans le journal le progrès de lyon une
longue interview économique qui paraît
presque en même temps que celle accordée
aujourd'hui sur le même thème par
monsieur jacques chirac au journal le
monde philippe sassier oui j'ai
redresser l'économie française dit
raymond barre je propose un plan de
redressement rétorque jacques chirac on
voit les propos sur la situation
économique deviennent de plus en plus
des arguments politiques les réponses du
premier ministre aux questions posées
par le progrès de liausson londres
complètes et précises voilà comment on
peut les regione en 1979 cent mille
emplois ont été créés contre 60 milles
en 1978 défendre le franc c'est défendre
l'emploi c'est servir l'emploi je me
refuse et je me refuserai toujours à
traiter les problèmes du chômage par une
politique de stimulation de l'activité
en clair il n'y aura pas de relance il
ne faut pas se laisser impressionner par
les prévisions pessimistes sur
l'économie et sur le chômage dans les
prochaines années
quant à l indice
réplique le premier ministre contre
attaque posant ses propres questions
comment supporter la hausse du pétrole
semblait sans la répercuter sur l'
indice des prix fallait-il gounod
maintenir un contrôle médiévale je le
cite sur les prix qui a été condamnée
par tous les pays occidentaux fallait-il
ou non remettre de l'ordre dans les
tares et des entreprises publiques
jacques chirac
de son côté dans son interview au nom ne
propose plus de mesures de relance comme
par le passé mais il parle d'une
nouvelle croissance ils veulent imiter
l'embauchent des fonctionnaires il veut
réduire les dépenses de l'état il
propose de lutter davantage contre la
fraude fiscale et de davantage également
aidé les investissements et le suggère
également un impôt exceptionnel sur les
grandes fortunes jacques chirac qui fixe
comme priorité absolue la résorption du
chômage qu'il nomme le cancer du corps
social a en tout cas un point commun
avec monsieur raymond barre il ne nie
pas la crise que la france thales comme
la plupart des grands pays occidentaux
depuis 20 ans les recherches sur la
reproduction ont surtout porté sur la
contraception après un essor
considérable dans ce domaine la
recherche médicale se penche aujourd'hui
sur les difficultés de fécondité des
couples qui veulent avoir des enfants
c'était justement aujourd'hui le thème
d'une réunion de l'institut national de
la santé et de la recherche médicale qui
étudie un certain nombre d' enquête sur
la fée conte habits fécondabilité ce
n'est pas facile à dire et la vie
sexuelle des milliers de couples martin
amr agneaux j'espère que vous allez être
plus clair que moi mais on vit à l'ère
de la contraception c'est à dire des
enfants voulu désiré le problème est
qu'un certain nombre de couples qui
voudrait avoir des enfants n'en ont pas
et que globalement les occidentaux ont
moins d'enfants que par le passé alors
l'inserm a consacré une part importante
de ses recherches aux études sur la
fertilité biologique mais aussi
statistiques l'inserm a interrogé des
hommes des femmes des couples
volontaires qui avaient l'intention
d'avoir un enfant et qui ont accepté de
donner des détails surtout leur âge leur
poids leur taille leur mode de vie leur
alimentation leur température leur cycle
leurs rapports sexuels pour déterminer
dans quelles conditions j'allais dire
statistiques que s'établir au mieux une
grossesse alors je ne peux pas tout vous
dire en deux minutes mais j'ai retenu un
certain nombre de fois alors à retenir
qu'en moyenne 90 % des français peuvent
avoir une conception
dans l'année oui le désir et la plupart
dans les quatre à six mois qui suivent
leur décision à retenir aussi que sur
100 produits de conception obtenu 50%
des embryons sont mal formés non viables
et disparaissent très tôt ce qui fait
que longtemps ils sont passés inaperçus
à retenir encore que ces couples normaux
c'est 90% là ont les mêmes résultats
qu'ils aient eu recours ou pas à la
contraception avant alors il faut
retenir enfin que la stérilité plus rare
qu'on le croit mais l'ipo fécondité
c'est à dire les mauvais couple où la
femme n'est pas très féconde
le mari pas très fécond n'aboutissent
pas toujours à des grossesses et c'est
chez ceux là que l'on voit le maximum de
choses alors grâce à l'insémination
artificielle
on peut par exemple connaître certaines
femmes l'heure précise de la conception
il on a découvert un fait très curieux
par exemple c'est que on croyait que la
femme était surtout féconde au moins
dans même de son ovulation et grâce à
l'insémination artificielle on a
découvert qu'elle était féconde
trois jours plus tôt que prévu les trois
jours qui précèdent cette ovulation pour
ce qui concerne les spermatozoïdes qui
sont contenus dans le sperme à raison de
60 à 98 millions par centimètre cube
on s'est aperçu que ce nombre est
parfois beaucoup plus faible mais que
par insémination artificielle même avec
2 millions de spermatozoïdes seulement
on peut obtenir une grossesse en
revanche il ya un énorme problème c'est
celui de la mobilité
alors on s'est penchés aussi sur ce
problème actuellement on peut traquer un
spermatozoïde au microscope et suivre sa
mobilité
on sait maintenant enrichir le sperme le
concentré pour augmenter le nombre
trouver des stimulants pharmacologique
pour améliorer la mobilité et je peux
vous donner un résultat très
encourageant
il ya parfois 30 % de succès alors ses
recherches sont en cours elles vont
continuer un certain nombre de sur un
certain nombre de pistes et l'on pense
que bientôt on va pouvoir favoriser tous
ces vipères philippot fécondité
pardonnez moi bien entendu il reste et
série était insoluble
merci je n'ai pas trouvé de transition
pour passer au cinéma mais nous y
arrivons quand même soirée des oscars à
hollywood cette nuit le cinéma américain
couronne ses meilleurs réalisateurs et
acteurs hollywood un nom qui fait rêver
qui à lui seul évoque un monde
fantastique peuplé de stars milliardaire
extravagantes mais comme le dit le
dicton populaire hollywood aujourd'hui
ça n'est plus ce que c'était et le
cinéma américain lui aussi a changé
une enquête dans nos correspondants aux
états unis claude véniel
ce sont les grands d'hollywood les
médias aux compagnies zone en
prestigieux métro goldwin meyer columbia
fox warner par aman fini versol
autrefois les maîtres du jeu et tous ou
presque aujourd'hui rachetée par des
banques des multinationales ou des
compagnies pétrolières
les folies les visons les grandes
premières c'est fini les stars aussi
relégué au musée de cire que s'est il
passé
jusqu'en 1947 toute la fabrication d'un
film était faite sous le même toit de
l'idée jusqu'à la production et même la
diffusion les salles appartenait aux
studios mgm par exemple posséder
soixante et une vedette dix sept
réalisateurs 50 sénat risque tous
salariés sous contrat de longue durée
gary cooper resté 24 ans sous contrat
avec mgm ont fabriqué les stars et on
les faisait durer en 1947 la loi
antitrust obliger les grandes compagnies
à vendre leur salle la télévision dans
les années 50 commencé à retenir les
spectateurs chez eux c'était la crise et
les studios rendez leur liberté aux
stars on ouvrait le marché de l'emploi
n'y pour lutter contre la télévision les
grandes compagnies se lancer dans les
superproductions
sur écran géant avec des budgets
roquettes
cléopâtre sera le dernier et le plus
grand flop de l'histoire du cinéma pour
conserver leur clientèle les compagnies
louent à prix d'or les stars qui
remplissent les salles
certains ne s'en relèveront pas et
aujourd'hui on déroule le tapis rouge
sous les pieds les avocats ce sont eux
les nouveaux maîtres avec les agents
réunir une équipe pour monter un film
est aujourd'hui un casse tête chinois
écrivain scénariste réalisateur metteur
en scène et acteur ont chacun leurs
agents dans cet imbroglio juridique
qu'est la rédaction d'un contrat
les avocats font fortune et contrôler le
marché opérant à tous les échelons
ils sont les seuls à connaître les
montants des contrats les réussites et
la côte de chacun ils peuvent imposer ou
s'imposer certains sont maintenant
scénaristes réalisateurs ou pourvoyeur
de fonds
on ne fait plus de poésie mais du
business on gagne beaucoup d'argent
quand on est avocat dans l'industrie du
cinéma et des avocats dans ces villes
moi je parle pas de moi je veux pas être
aussi un discret mais beaucoup beaucoup
d'avocats dans ces villes qui garde
énormément d'argent absolument pas ce
qu'ils ont parfois des participations
dans les bénéfices des clients parfois
il travaille alors dans l'horaire mais
oui ça peut être très rentable
alors fini hollywood pas du tout on n'a
même jamais fait aussi bien
garces élabore le marché de la
révolution technologique dans les rues
de los angeles fleurissent les émetteurs
ou capteurs de satellites
les compagnies qui ont perdu la bataille
de la télévision gratuite veulent gagner
celle du câble des satellites de la
télévision payante des vidéocassettes et
bientôt des vidéos disque avec les
heures un énorme marché qui fragmentent
les bases du cinéma et ouvre ses portes
petite compagnie pour des films à petit
budget de style européen pour répondre à
cette clientèle
le cinéma produira des films plus
spécialisée et on essaiera de garder le
public des salles un public jeune avec
des films à gadgets électroniques et
super vedettes comme bando newman mais
le film en même temps qu'il passera dans
les salles sera vendu sur cassette pour
consommation à la maison cinéma et
télévision seront des alliés pour une
orgie d'image dans cette bataille
que deviendra la qualité on répond ici
on fabriquera plus de films il y en aura
plus de meilleur c'est comme les livres
seuls les bons se vendre
mais météo pour terminer demain sur la
moitié sud du pays le temps sera très
nuageux avec des pluies localement
orageuses sur les cévennes et le midi
méditerranéen où les vents de sud est
seront forts et les températures en
baisse dans l'intérieur sans grand
changement par contre sur le littoral
sur la moitié nord du pays il y aura des
ondes et locales sur la bretagne sud du
bassin parisien
le temps sera beau ailleurs en
particulier de l'alsace aux flandres
avec vent modéré de sud-est et
températures stationnaires voilà les
amateurs de météo auront été ce soit
complètement informe le dernier journal
en fin de programme c'est hervé claude
et dans quelques minutes question de
temps présentée par louis blériot vous
proposera la première émission de la
grande campagne organisée par la
direction de l'information d'antenne 2
sur le thème le temps du temps de vivre
sans émissions en un an ou feront
connaître toutes les initiatives
développées partout vous permettre de
prendre votre temps
ce soir un grand reportage réalisé dans
une entreprise de pau entreprise dans
laquelle a débuté il ya deux années une
expérience d'aménagement du temps de
travail et de suppression du travail à
la chaîne
deux ans donc après le début de cette
expérience antenne 2 est retourné sur
place à faire un premier bilan donc tout
de suite après ce journal question de
temps le temps de vivre je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée donc sur antenne 2
à demain bonsoir